yeah obviously coming from your
background
um and you obviously have a special like
uh perspective on
La for sure
what is like I know LA's always been
crazy but I feel like it gets publicized
more and more now right because we
always see oh yeah because it's
Instagram and [ __ ] Tick Tock and you
see in all types but you think it has
gotten more intense since like the EDD
[ __ ] dried up for sure well uh
let me put it like this Ed put a lot of
money in hands of people that weren't
used to having a lot of money you know
right and they and a lot of people
started Living a certain lifestyle that
maybe didn't put in the work to live
that lifestyle and grew accustomed to
going to eat at wherever they want right
Bossa Nova if you know what I mean
certain people grew accustomed to living
a lifestyle and portraying a certain
image that they maybe didn't know how to
how to maintain you know what I mean and
so when you live in
and what was there like eight a million
people in the city right and I'm sure
like six million of those eight million
are
close to the poverty poverty line or
under it you know what I mean and when
you highly
publicizing what you'd be wearing and
jewelry and posting your location and
you know what I'm saying like not trying
to say anybody did certain things but
but uh all of that kind of
draws in a certain type of
the viewership you know what I mean and
uh when people are looking at you uh
flexing all day yeah and doing this and
that and you in their city and these
this person you're struggling this
person got the
baby mama hitting them up like hey man
what's up with this child support or
what's up with this or they might not
have enough to pay rent it's easy for
somebody in in in in in our city to be
like man who on Instagram right now who
who over here
who's outside exactly bro like bro you
know there's like 20 spots in La that
people are actually yeah always like if
you just hang out in front of certain
restaurants you're like yo you if you
really wanted to get hit a leg walking
out every time you know that you know
that and there's and I I hate to say it
but
people need to
value themselves more than they value
their image you know I mean like yeah
like there's a certain like there's a
certain way people like to move now
because of Instagram and
social media and all that [ __ ] and like
you might get ahead in the uh you know
you might get them some more some
followers or something like that but you
putting yourself on a whole you like
yeah because when when you leave you're
meet you're dressed for everyone else
yeah dress for yourself exactly you're
trying to impress everybody yeah you
know but I used to fall
victim to that as well you know I mean
like and I used to to worry about like
damn if I if I if I show up over here to
go go do this show I got to have 12 12
[ __ ] with me and this and that
because I because I because I have on
this chain I got on this watch and I
want to make sure that I protect my own
investment right bro you see now bro I
don't got no jury on no nothing bro like
so if you got an issue with me you just
[ __ ] then you know what I mean like I
don't got anything you could
possibly want like
yeah anything like that I ain't carrying
around no stack like all my cash is in
my car on my account you know what I
mean like that's bad it's unnecessary
it's all ego it's not just that because
I've been on the other side of it before
and I know how easy it is to to to to
First somebody out here to really be
like Oh I'm attract this [ __ ]
down like bro I know how easy it is I
mean people throw the air tags on your
car like not even that bro like it's
really a very simple thing to do like
bro if you post if somebody else post on
like a flyer or something like this
person's performing at this time at this
place or they showing up to this event
or they showing up at this club bro it's
so easy like come on bro like if you
want to find anybody in La that's
actually out actively
I'm working you can get it done it's not
that I think like a lot of it too is
like
because a lot of security guards are
affiliated right do you think a lot of
times like those guys are give like
tipping people off or is it usually
I couldn't I don't want to put that on
the security guards like that bro
because it's really just people being
idiots or bro like if true if people are
out in in in in in La like but let's
just say like you like bowling or
something right at pins
200 people then already seen you at pins
and already told this person you can't
really say it everybody goes depends
that's what I'm saying like come on bro
like 200 people like people put
themselves in a situation where they
have to defend their life over over a
watch some [ __ ] there's a time and a
place for everything you know what I
mean there's a time to place or anything
you don't need to have that [ __ ] around
bro if if if the uh jewelry is what
makes you you then you ain't [ __ ] and
who are you you ain't [ __ ] anyway yeah I
heard somebody say that recently it's
like if you took away what you're best
at right
should start thinking about that like if
you like look at yourself you say yo my
whole life revolves around what I do the
best whatever that is whether you're a
rapper you're a musician oh for sure
maybe you're a video director whatever
it is what happens if you take that away
who are you exactly well if you know
what I mean exactly bro it has to be
like I don't know I feel like everybody
just needs to
really just be
self-aware more than anything yeah be
self-aware bro if if if you look like
food you're gonna get ate take yourself
off that plate don't don't give nobody
opportunity to even or move around feel
me like you gotta move or move right bro
yeah move right you know what I'm saying
like some people some people need to
check in bro like some people need to
check in and and know how to move around
not on some [ __ ] like oh let me check in
because I'm scared
yeah let me check in so so I can have
the lay of the land that people right
paying attention to me and telling me Oh
don't go over here or don't go over here
it's not cool like that like bro like
even like uh pnb my boy bro like yeah
that was wrong oh he was a great guy a
good good good dude bro like super good
dude me and him weren't super close but
we was cool bro like every time we met
it was always 100 respect he wasn't one
of them Hollywood dudes to act like they
don't know who you are after you just
met last week you feel me like he was a
solid dude bro and I wish he would have
been with anybody that would have been
like bro don't go over there you know I
don't go over there bro I don't go over
there I don't know anybody even though
you know me I don't go over there bro
come on bro yeah like that's not that's
not it bro yeah it's it's interesting
too because he had been here so long and
been around and you know he's been
around the right people at times and
it's like you would just think he would
know that yeah we're not the way bro
yeah you know what I mean